votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
alors j'ai annoncé ma candidature à la
présidence de france télévisions qui a
des petites précisions apportées et mais
petite beauté une beauté je vais vous
parler mon programme quand je serai à la
tête de france télé et le gars le gars
prend la grosse tête en avant oui quand
je serai président de france télé je
veux que tu m'appelles monseigneur une
fausse le buzz mais sans les connais je
peux vous dire que j'ai omis certains
des chroniqueurs avec moi par exemple je
mette jean michel maire pour l'émission
j'irai dormir chez vous chez vous à sauf
que ça s'appellera j'irai dormir chez
vous et je dirais à votre première
premier axe ou en tant que président je
rachète en ligue des champions ah ouais
et aux commentaires
je mets jean luc lemoine et gilles
verdez sa forme et puis suite à l'arrêt
de la carrière internationale de franck
ribéry lui un couple qui voulait chanter
en duo une chanson de serge gainsbourg
c'est justement franck ribéry et didier
deschamps bonjour étudiants
[Musique]
en équipe de france et je te retiens je
vaux pour java je viens
l'équipe de france mais je me retiens
lolo lolo de la la la la
lolo lolo c'est parti on appelle
françois hollande olalalala je n'en peux
plus
manuel valls a envie de vous connaître
moyens quand même à bien peut-être
changer de numéro
non mais attendez on va évoluer ce un
message précis dans les prisons monsieur
le président monsieur le président oui
pardon je dérangeais président je
m'appelle matthieu delormeau voiliers
qui je suis oui lieu merci beaucoup je
suis dans une émission de télé je suis
dans une émission de télévision en
direct monsieur président et mon rêve je
vais bien je les peins beaucoup de
tories j'irai très très vite mon rêve
mais c'est président ça serait de
déjeuner avec vous au moins de prendre
un verre manuel valls le souhaitait
également que je préférerais que ce soit
avec vous est ce que vous accepteriez
écoutez je vais y réfléchir je et ses
dates de leurs modèles
[Applaudissements]
la foule est venue me suis fait un petit
plaisir
j'ai demandé à marc antoine le bret le
diable tout
[Applaudissements]
la ministre qui nous fait l'honneur de
venir chanter pour nous puisque arnaud
montebourg a décidé de faire une reprise
ça lui coûtait monsieur courbet comme
j'ai quitté le gouvernement
j'ai effectivement fait une reprise pour
françois hollande pour manuel valls et
tous les sens du terme terre de l'elysée
s'est dit par pour la section dassault
aviation trois cas j'ai préféré partir
et m'isoler à lui comment tenir je suis
désolé j'ai côtoyé le projet waza pas je
me suis dit désolé françois venus les
gars désolé voilà salut qu'à sa tête
réagissez sur bouquet tout c'est que
lorsque tu veux me faire la nique à moi
tu as été générés et à danser un genre
des tangos pakistanais ils sortent pâles
kaboul est il sans mal cool tu as sorti
la kalachnikov
jean jaurès
la chanson c'est aussi bien sûr des duo
inoubliable
et on termine avec un duo qui risque
effectivement d'être difficile à oublier
puisque c'est nelson monfort et philippe
candeloro qui s'y colle ouais comme ça
tout à fait mensonger lien avec philippe
candeloro nous avons décidé de faire une
reprise d'un petit groupe punk assez peu
connu les pins que du daf tout comme on
les appelle en anglais
daft punk je lance un appel à tous
quelle somme ira paul maritz gadson we
are all right to get lucky à vous mon
cher philippe candeloro on est debout
toute la nuit debout toute la nuit nous
tout ce qu'on veut c'est nick et nous
tout ce qu'on veut c'est déglingué à
tout le moins nous tout ce qu'on veut
c'est mickey nous tout ce qu'on veut
c'est à jean michel à toi
c'était marc antoine
bien vrai
[Applaudissements]